so it's about an hour ago now that it
was confirmed by buckingham palace that
planned virtual engagements that her
majesty was due to do today she has
decided that she won't do those and in a
short statement they said as her majesty
is still experiencing mild like symptoms
she's decided not to undertake her
planned virtual engagements today but
will continue
with light duties so i don't think it's
necessarily the news that many of us
would have wanted of course we'd far
rather see her carrying on and see some
pictures of her today doing an
engagement but don't forget when you are
95 years old also when you are the queen
it's a little bit different from her
from us really soldiering on through
cold like symptoms she wants of course
always to be seen to to look her best
she'd have to get up get dressed get her
makeup on get her hair done and the last
thing that the palace would want is
pictures out there of the queen not
looking her best now yesterday it was
confirmed by the palace the engagements
were still in the diary for this week
and that the queen intended to do as
much of that as she could and that's
after it was confirmed on sunday that
she tested positive
for covid i understand that there are
still other engagements in the diary
this week
for example every wednesday she has an
audience of some sort with the prime
minister whether virtually or whether in
person so that's certainly something
that won't be uh missing from the diary
and also in recent weeks she's been
overseeing the handover of ambassadorial
papers so remotely from windsor at
buckingham palace the ambassadors have
turned up and she's she's holding held
an audience with them we don't know
exactly what engagement she's had to
cancel today but i suspect it was
probably something uh like that but of
course this is not necessarily the news
that we would have wanted to hear i
think most of us would rather hear that
she is she's up and about but as the
palace stressed she is continuing with
light duties which i suspect probably
still means meeting up with her private
secretary going through those red boxes
full of papers that she receives every
day
it's not been an easy year for the queen
has it
no it hasn't and if you just think
last week in itself was was difficult
enough we had of course um
prince andrew settling that case with
virginia dufrey and all the controversy
around that the metropolitan police last
week confirming that they are now
investigating
uh the prince of wales is charity when
it comes to cash for honours allegations
you've also got prince prince harry
taking the home office uh to court so no
it has certainly not been the start to
the platinum jubilee that the queen
would want it and the last thing that
anyone would want her majesty and the
royal family certainly is for her to
have now contracted covid and of course
she's 95 years old she's due to turn 96
in april and of course she had those
health issues just before christmas
which i think
has really focused our minds on the
queen her age and her frailty in a way
that we probably haven't
in recent years because she's enjoyed
such good health during her 70 year
reign but i think for the palace now
it's all about managing the messaging
around this of course the royal family
are notoriously private when it comes to
their medical matters but the palace
will want to make sure that they are
still putting out those messages of
reassurance and that's why they're
stressing that she is carrying on with
light duties and also that they're
really going to play it by ear when it
comes to the week ahead when it comes to
engagements